Speaker 1: We have seen over the last four
years, decade, 15 years almost pick pick your
timeframe.
Much of the American right wing riddled with
projection projection where they claim the
left is doing that, which they are actually
doing so.
One example is the right loves to say we are
for free speech and the left is against free
speech.
And in reality, it's often the truth that
the right is for free speech only in their
very narrow view.
For as long as it's convenient to them and
then they are very quickly against it, they
don't care about free speech once it's no
longer convenient to them.
Social media regulation is a great example
of this.
As soon as the lion's share of COVID disinformation
is coming from the right, they're no longer
OK.
Letting Twitter or YouTube or Facebook decide
what's OK on their platform.
They want to mandate that these platforms
allow COVID disinformation.
Now, on the other side of that, they claim
to be against business regulation.
That's a principle we are against regulating
businesses until Twitter is banning the people
they want to ban from Twitter.
And all of a sudden they say, we need to regulate
Twitter to force them to allow certain speech.
You guys understand this concept.
The principle is abandoned as soon as it's
inconvenient.
So along these lines, there is this topic
of of books and banning books, and they claim
the left wants to ban books that are inconvenient
to them.
That being said, I've heard nothing about
wanting to ban Bobby Kennedy Jr's anti-vaccine
anti Dr. Fauci book or whatever other book
what we want and speaking for myself, I want
to educate people so they never fall for buying
these dumb books in the first place.
But this is not about me, because now there's
a rash of right wingers wanting to ban and
in some cases succeeding at banning all sorts
of books from all over the place, often under
the guise of protecting kids.
That's the explanation that they will often
give a few examples of this.
A Tennessee school board has voted unanimously
to ban the Pulitzer Prize winning book.
Now this is about the Holocaust in cartoon
form.
Some of you emailed me about this.
They want to ban it from their eighth grade
curriculum.
They say it has objectionable language and
a nudity cartoon nudity, of course, and there
similar campaigns underway in all sorts of
other districts in more than 30 states.
At this point, state line has been investigating
this, and they will often say these books
are pornographic merely because they depict
an LGBTQ experience.
Sometimes a black character with an LGBTQ
experience.
Huffington Post HuffPost Now it's called reports
that in Texas, the Republican governor, Greg
Abbott.
That is sort of taking advantage of this effort
to pull, quote, pornographic or obscene books
from school libraries after Republican Representative
Matt Krauss circulated a list of 800 books
that he believes crosses the line, and the
vast majority of these books were written
by women or people of color or LGBTQ writers,
according to the Dallas Morning News.
So consider how many of their own supposed
principles they are violating.
Here they are for free speech, but they've
got a long list of books that they want to
ban.
They are for doing what's best for people,
yet.
They're not letting education experts, the
teachers decide, Is this book a good teaching
tool for my students or not?
They are deciding from above the elected officials,
that is, and the reasons that they give for
banning most of these books should actually
apply to the Bible.
But of course, the Bible is always OK.
Murder in the Bible, incest, genocide, sexual
content.
It's all in the Bible, but the Bible is beyond
reproach.
That's a sacred cow.
So putting all of this aside, a great way
to get kids interested in a lot of these books
is to ban them.
I mean, I mean, I I'm against the book banning
on principle, of course, but I also recognize
that banning these books might get kids interested
in the books as well.
The urge to do something you're not supposed
to do can sort of end up being like an adrenaline
adrenaline rush.
But that being said, many of these books can
easily be read online, but it is again an
example of it's really one of the major stories
of conservatives.
It's not even conservatism of reactionary,
right?
Thinking of the last era of this era, which
is our prince.
Nothing is more important than our principles.
Of course, our principles are sacred until
the outcome of those principles is inconvenient
when it comes to speech, when it comes to
censorship, when it comes to regulation, when
it comes to elections at the end of the day.
And this is just the latest example.
Let me know if this is going on in your state,
in your locality.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that the David Pakman show is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners like you,
people who watch clips on YouTube or listen
to the podcast, listen on our various radio
affiliates or even watch on free speech TV.
You can sign up and get a membership cheap,
very cheap at join Pacman dot com.
You can also use the coupon code WOUD 22 to
get a discount if you please not means tested
available to everybody.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com.